i can't say that i regret doing three
languages at the same time but
if i had the discipline
i would focus on one now hi steve
kaufman here and uh today i want to talk
about my experience in learning or
trying to learn several languages at the
same time a subject i've talked about
before
uh remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications
if you follow me on a podcast service
please leave a review
so i've talked about this before and
this is something that comes up a lot
people who
do learn several languages at the same
time or would like to learn several
languages at the same time is it a good
idea not a good idea and so forth
so i have tended to say it's best to
focus on one language however there are
advantages to
trying to learn more than one language
at one time
and basically that's sort of the
experiment that i embarked on it's got
to be three years ago
where i said i'm gonna learn three
middle eastern languages turkish arabic
and persian or farsi
and my reason for doing that
was first of all the reasons were one
i didn't want to go
i know it takes a long time to learn any
one language so if i were to focus on
arabic then for two years i would not do
any persian or turkish
so if i were to learn all three
languages it might take me six years or
more to achieve any kind of a level in
any one of them so i said well
if i go three months on one three months
on the other
you know i kind of maintain all three of
them i won't move along as quickly
but i won't forget as much and so that's
kind of what i've been doing for the
last three years
uh i decided to stop the turkish because
one of the obstacles for me in
persian and in arabic was simply the
writing system the problem the
difficulty in learning a writing system
is not so much
learning what the different symbols or
characters or letters represent
it's actually training your brain to
read
and to convert you know
[Music]
writing into meaning instantly the way
we do in our own writing system and it's
just an awful lot harder
i still find it easier to read in czech
or polish than in russian or ukrainian
even though i speak russian certainly a
lot better than czech
you can't sort of discount the sort of
sense of familiarity with a script that
we grew up with
and of course you know the cyrillic
script is essentially parallel to the
latin script so it's not that difficult
to learn
uh on the other hand persian and arabic
present me at least they were difficult
for me so i said okay i'm going to focus
on them and leave the turkish
so i've been doing that and i would say
that really
my progress has suffered
i have a smattering of certainly arabic
and persian not only that in arabic i've
decided to expose myself to levantine
arabic and
egyptian arabic which also introduces a
level of confusion
but on and the reason i'm doing that is
that i want to be able to understand
movies from lebanon movies from egypt
and uh
arabic speaking people they speak their
own dialect to each other and they
somehow manage to communicate across
different dialects with the exception of
people from north africa
so i kind of feel if i'm doing my arabic
thing
then i should kind of be familiar with
levantine arabic and egyptian arabic and
actually the two egyptian and and
levantine are closer to each other than
they are to standard arabic but you
still need the standard arabic in order
to read in order to understand
you know
radio political podcasts and things of
that nature
so
my arabic is kind of at a standstill
uh persian i think i'm doing better at
i have
it's more comfortable easier for me to
speak in persian when i speak to my
tutor
but
there's no question that if i were to
focus on one i would be much much
further ahead
and so then i say to myself okay
why don't i just focus on persian now
and try to get it up to a decent level
uh but then of course there's always
that cheese you know
i come across an interesting something
in lebanton arabic in fact i bought a
book recently
um on
levantine arabic grammar and everything
arabic verbs and it's fun kind of the
lead through that so it's kind of hard
to let go
but i probably should and no sooner have
i done that than i i was scheduled to
have a an interview or a conversation
with
a youtuber who speaks japanese and
turkish so i said geez i better brush up
on my turkish so i go back to my turkish
and
after an initial three months focused on
turkish i did have an exit video as i
call it in turkish where i actually was
able to speak i couldn't do that now
uh but then i go back to turkish go back
to the mini stories go back to a bunch
of stuff and i realized just how much i
have forgotten
and also how many words there are for me
to learn
so i kind of know where in turkish
uh not where i would like to be in
arabic
a little closer where i to where i would
like to be in persian and now
it turns out that i have an interview or
a discussion with
someone from korea
and so i said you know and i should try
to brush up my korean i've spent a lot
of time on korean over the years on and
get off again
and it's really not at a level that i
would like i'm sure if i if you know
when i have been in korea i can have
sort of casual conversation with people
i do have theoretically a large passive
vocabulary but in fact i struggle so
i've been doing a bit of korean plus
i'm down here in palm springs again you
can see my fake bookshelf behind me
and we're at a golf course and there's a
large group of young koreans here
who are this is sort of like their golf
camp with their instructors and
everything so i like to go and chat a
bit and uh
and watch them hit the ball and see if i
can imitate them
so the korean is back so like
there's just no end and so then the
question really is is it really
worthwhile doing all this why bother
and so
i think the question of whether you
should learn
more than one language at the same time
or even as a polyglot even if you're not
doing it at the same time you are
entertaining you are balancing like this
this uh you know
juggler who's got all these balls in the
air
uh
obviously you can't
maintain them all you know you're
catching stuff that's falling down you
can't maintain them all at the same at
the same level
um
so then you i think it very much depends
on the the sort of uh
you know what your needs are at any
given time
and i definitely enjoy exploring
languages even the little bit of turkish
that i have i'm very happy that i've
i've done that i'm happy because i enjoy
when i go back to turkish i hear the
sounds of turkish
uh when i watch a series in turkish i
get a bit of a sense of what they're
talking about or the odd word here and
there
and i'm very happy that i that i did
that i'm very happy that i did what i
did in korean even though it's not quite
where i would like it to be so i think
the simple answer is you know should you
study more than one language at the same
time or even should you study more than
one language should you focus on one
language and try to be as good as you
possibly can be in that language
that's in i finally you know in the end
that's up to you
i i very much applaud people who want to
become as good as they can be in
language x
but at the same time
uh
it's such a wonderful thing and i think
back to
that great
gentle giant
moses mccormick who
tragically you know died at a very young
age but whose life was spent exploring
all kinds of unconnected languages from
every corner of the world and probably
not achieving
you know c2 or anything in any of those
languages but certainly capable of
handling conversations in a variety of
languages so it depends what you want to
do you want to explore you want to be a
perfectionist
but if you want to do well in the
language then i certainly think you have
to focus and
i can't say that i regret doing three
languages at the same time but
if i had the discipline
i would focus on one now i would go
and focus on persian and get it up to a
really good level
and then go back in and pick up the
pieces
uh of my arabic or or turkish
and i've still got pieces to pick up in
korean and czech and greek and romanian
and so
that in a sense comes with the territory
if you're going to be a polyglot and
enjoy exploring languages you're never
going to be satisfied uh with your level
in any of them
but you're going to enjoy them all
so
just a bit of a ramble uh on the subject
of studying more than one language at
the same time
thank you for listening i i hope you
find that useful and i think i'll leave
you
my exit videos after three months of
persian and three months of turkish
and
of those two i think i've improved in
persian since then i haven't improved in
turkish
bye for now